l'exécutif tente de rassurer les
français inquiet d'une vague épidémique
selon le porte-parole du gouvernement il
n'y a pas lieu de paniquer pour la
reprise des cours
tout a été mis en place pour protéger
les enfants et les enseignants pour la
rentrée scolaire
on a choisi le port du masque dès 11 ans
on verra si les adaptations sont
nécessaires
gabriella talent qui a profité de sa
prise de parole ce dimanche pour revenir
sur la non gratuité des masques à
l'école une décision vivement critiquée
il n'y a pas de raison que l'on
distribue des masques à des familles qui
ont les moyens de les payer il faut
cibler les publics que l'on accompagne
les foyers modestes
de son côté le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a annoncé une succession de
réunions pour trouver des solutions pour
le bien-être des enseignants un prochain
grenelle axée sur les salaires et les
conditions de travail
le chantier de la deuxième partie du
quinquennat c'est la revalorisation du
métier sur le plan financier mais plus
généralement pour améliorer le bien-être
au travail
c'est pourquoi je lance un grenelle des
professeurs d'ici à octobre nous
discuterons de la hausse des
rémunérations pour 2021
grâce aux 400 millions d'euros
supplémentaires obtenus et à partir de
novembre
nous négocierons pour définir une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle
mais ça passe aussi par une
transformation profonde du système
éducatif et gestion des ressources
humaines place des enseignants dans la
société des maîtres heureux ce sont des
élèves heureux une forme de sérénité
affichée au sein du gouvernement qui ne
rassure pas pour autant dans une tribune
publiée ce week-end sur le site du
parisien
un collectif de médecins appellent à
durcir les précautions au sein des
établissements scolaires
et en ce lundi de prérentrée pour près
de huit cent soixante dix mille
enseignants un vent de colère souffle
déjà professeurs étudiants et lycéens
doivent se retrouver en fin de journée
devant l'inspection d'académie de
seine-et-marne à melun
des manifestants qui veulent dénoncer la
gestion catastrophique selon eux de la
crise sanitaire
un appel au rassemblement lancé par une
intersyndicale et soutenus par des
parents d'élèves